Hello, how are you? Natale Lancelot greets you,
and with your brief IU information, it's
nothing in Spanish. A suspect is in
custody after barricading himself
inside a service station. This
incident happened at the Sherwood located
on Bonanza near Matters Luther
King' Boulevard, Las  Authorities
ended up convincing the subject
to turn himself in peacefully. This
entrenchment caused the closure of the
intersection for several hours
on Tuesday morning. Authorities
arrested the man in connection with the
shooting that left a
Chinatown waiter seriously hospitalized.
Detectives gave  with the whereabouts
of 23 year old brian gaston anderson
near from rim road and maryline parkway
police say gaston anderson
shot chen line one inside
shanghai 6 11 times restaurant located
above spring mountain brow the waiter is
still fighting for his life in  the
hospital is expected to survive 2b gas
golden knights will be without some d  e
his starting players on
tuesday against the angels kings
due to several positive cases of
kobe coach peter berg and player
bread auden were the last to
enter kobe's roster before the holidays
were already on it  álex pietrangelo and in
jenín is donated the nhl requests a
10-day quarantine to comply with
the max protocol to be et and mark
stone in robin lerner be in doubt
due to injuries and now we turn to
the weather forecast today we will have
chances of rain with maximum
At 48 degrees,
temperatures are expected to remain
below 50 for the rest of the week with
cloudy skies and drizzle by 2022
the lows will be below 30
degrees so bundle up please,
nice day greets you  natale lancelot and
with her short newscasts inews now
spanish
[Music]